Hey,
what's going on?
What's going on?
You'd spill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
August 22nd,
2016 what's going on?
I why?
Yeah,
Nigga.
What's going on with the ashes on these fucking divers?
What?
You got it on fucking TV?
I'm supposed to ignore that.
There's no reason the suits have to be cut like that,
so obviously I made that.
They want to show their answers.
Huh?
Maybe it creates less of a splash.
If the bottom of your bathing suit as up over your ass cheek.
I have no idea.
Is this synchronized diving?
Did I ever tell you how much I don't like synchronize shit,
man.
Synchronized swimming is both unbelievably difficult and the stupidest fucking
thing.
Human beings a engaging.
Uh Huh.
Let me come up out of the water and they do the dumb shit and they got the song
playing.
Is that athletic?
Sure.
I mean,
yeah.
I mean then dancing is athletic,
right?
Which I would agree with,
but it's not a sport.
You have to be in the water.
It's dancing in the water.
You run the Water Olympics.
The Olympic Committee has a sign that it's a sport.
Yeah.
But they've also gotten rid of like baseball and shit.
You know,
they've taken actual sports in.
They've been like,
yeah,
no,
but then all of a sudden you,
you,
you show up and uh,
you and your friend get in the water and you're like five,
six,
seven,
eight,
Charleston,
Charleston.
Right.
Ooh,
boo boo.
Right.
And all of a sudden that's a sport.
You can have your fucking headphones off.
Honestly,
this whole thing.
And then on the buckets,
you're not on the podcast,
so you're not participating.
So all those other times when you wanted to participate,
you want to talk Conor Mcgregor and Nate Diaz,
you didn't see him.
We both didn't see it.
You know why?
Because we try to be honest when it comes to downloading shit.
Yeah.
We were here,
uh,
say night.
The fucking fight didn't first of all come on until like four in the morning or
something.
Italy time,
three in the morning.
And um,
I actually searched how to legally watch the UFC on the internet.
And for,
for the life of me,
I couldn't find a place.
God knows there was 58 websites telling me how to do it illegally.
I couldn't do that.
Right.
Okay.
What kind of an asshole when I be shitting on people for downloading my specials
for free.
And then I watched Conor McGregor first,
Nate Diaz for free.
Um,
so I've taped the fight,
but of course I went online and I had to see,
I had to find out who won.
So congratulations to Conor McGregor and Nate Diaz.
Cause I heard it was one of the,
uh,
one of the best UFC fights ever.
Five fucking rounds.
And,
um,
this is the conspiracy theories and theorists in me.
Um,
you knew that if it was going to the judge's Conor McGregor was going to win.
Okay?
And I'm not shitting on Conor.
I'm not shitting on it.
I'm just saying at the end of the fucking day,
all right,
UFC is show business,
all right?
And there's no fucking way that after you made back to the future part one and
back to the future,
part two and you see the ticket sales,
you know everybody's going to pay a ticket to back to the future part three.
However,
nobody's going to fucking watch it if McFly wins the first fucking two times.
Although we did didn't Ania did Marty McFly when the,
they all have happy endings,
right?
There's no empire strikes back in the back to the future.
Nia,
Nia does take you off your headphones.
If you gotta be in the room,
I'm going to interact with you.
Yes.
So is this,
Marty McFly wins all of the back to the futures,
right?
There's no empire strikes back one where the,
where the,
the uh,
hello McFly guy.
The guy knocks on his head,
comes back and no.
Does he ever win one?
No.
To justify part three.
I don't know.
Was that the one with the,
that was the western?
Yeah.
All I'm saying isn't it?
You knew,
okay.
If it went to the judges,
they got to give it to Conor McGregor so they can justify fucking part three.
Because if Nate,
when's the first two?
What the fuck?
Then Connor fights him again and then goes one and two.
Nate's still wins two out of three,
right?
Sure.
Yeah,
exactly.
Boy,
you go see you agree with me every once in a while.
Oh yeah.
Oh Jesus.
Um,
what does that have to do?
And actually the future is far as like,
yeah,
if I was watching the fight and it went to the cards and went to the judges,
I'm sorry.
Okay.
And it was going to be a decision.
You have to think that they're going to give it to Connor,
so then it's one to one,
so then they can fucking make more money on part three.
Right.
Oh,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
All right.
I'm going to be,
I'm being a Douche right now cause I didn't see the fight.
I'm not trying to take anything away from Conor Mcgregor.
How great was that press conference,
by the way?
Did you watch it?
No.
Uh,
I love the press conference.
First of all,
Nate Diaz,
one of the great fucking people ever in,
in a,
in a press conference.
I love that dude does not suffer fools.
And if you don't fight for a fucking living and you ask a dumb question,
he's not going to energy his way through it.
He's just going to let the question fucking die.
Like when they asked those dumb questions going on.
Right.
You all,
we've been hearing things [inaudible] is going to be,
yeah,
try to keep it standing up.
Whoa.
What do you think about it?
Just pauses and goes,
well,
you know,
we'll uh,
we'll see when the fight happens and then that's it.
I love that he does that to people.
And I also hate the fact that was talking to this about the other night that
people think Nate Diaz,
there's like something wrong with them or that he's dumb or anything like that.
Like that you could achieve,
you could become a champion and be stupid and people think it's all like fucking
natural ability.
You don't want to do any,
I'm going to stop talking to you because I can clearly see they're looking at
me.
You just put your sunglasses on.
It's the last day of her vacation.
You want to go outside.
All right,
I'll see you later.
Um,
he also,
he also got busted smoking weed through a vaporizer Assam ship.
It isn't after he just went through all the,
the,
that level of physical trauma,
you know what I mean?
That's probably the best thing he could've done.
Right.
All right.
Do you need any help with that?
Nia?
Opening the door there because if you're going to leave,
I'd appreciate it if you'd do it now.
Oh,
Jesus.
Hey,
yeah,
go.
Yeah,
you've got to watch out for the,
uh,
for the curtain rod there
and it's threatening manner.
Cause I felt like somebody hit me with a club.
Oh,
oh my God.
The other night.
Let's stay focused here.
So Jesus,
Nia,
um,
all these people that think Nate Diaz is dumb.
You think I love how I hit my head and you laughed at me after I get done saying
that Nate Diaz is not fucking dumb.
I hate people keep saying that.
The guy is fucking hilarious.
He's one of the greatest fighters of all fucking time.
You don't become a champion.
Just,
you know what it is.
There's two types of smart.
Okay.
You got like book smart,
which is respected and then you've got other people that are that fucking tap
into the matrix and they could feel vibes and they have instinct and all that,
and those fucking nerds who write all the newspapers.
Who are the journalists?
Those unathletic cons.
They're the ones who sit there.
They can't read anybody.
They'll walk up to a fucking serial killer and have no idea they were about
ready to get the old fucking right there.
Fred get thrown into a trunk.
Right?
Huh?
I know that killed me.
That was that.
Yeah.
All my life,
I've seen amazing champions get labeled as that by fucking nerds who would
strike out playing fucking kickball because they don't understand.
They don't understand.
They just don't fucking get it.
You know what I mean?
I swear to God.
This is why I respect all professional fighters.
As I've said this before,
you could literally tell a toddler what punch to throw at me.
You could then tell me what punched the toddler was going to throw me and I
still couldn't slip it.
I still,
I don't get where you look.
I don't know how the fuck you tell.
It's common.
The hand is quicker than the I.
My head is the size of a Macy's Day fucking float.
I get hit every fucking time.
Every fucking time.
I remember growing up,
like they used to think Henderson was dumb
because he had a couple of crazy fucking stories.
He spoke about himself in the third person.
Oh,
by the way,
he had more lead off home runs than anybody in the history of baseball.
More stolen bases than anybody in the history of the baseball.
The baseball of baseball,
sorry,
had a couple of fucking drinks or eight today.
Um,
okay.
To the ability to lead off a first at a professional level,
read the Pitcher,
figure out his corpse is,
tell his timing,
whatever,
and decide when he's going to the plate and when he isn't with a national
audience.
Millions of people are watching during the fucking world series to,
to think that somebody can do that and they just think like,
oh,
it's just instinct.
He's just born that way.
Like it's the same way people look at fucking,
I dunno,
anything they don't understand,
they just try to overly simplify it.
Um,
I fucking love the press conference that Nate Diaz had and that Conor McGregor
had both of their styles.
Conor McGregor obviously showing up late on purpose,
trying to do some psych out thing.
And then Nate's like,
I,
you're going to show up late and I'm going to leave early.
I already answered my questions.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Then they start throwing water bottles of water at each other.
All that was doing was selling the last fucking whatever fucking 10 million pay
per views that they needed.
It was perfect.
Both of them did a great fucking job.
I'm going to actually going to watch it when I get back
on a,
I fly back tomorrow.
It's the end of the vacation,
right?
MMM.
I can't wait to watch it,
but uh,
I'm actually,
I'm this vacation.
Yeah.
But so fucking amazing.
But I'm ready to go back.
I was ready to go back two days ago.
Um,
you know,
there is a point when you're on vacation where you got to take off the Mickey
mouse ears and be like,
alright,
I need to function as a fucking human,
a productive human being again.
MMM.
I gotta tell you man,
the greatest fucking time I've had in a while.
MMM.
The Amalfi coast,
I'm telling you,
it's touristy is shit.
It's fucking,
there's a lot of bad food for Italy here because it's so fucking touristy.
But if you go on the Internet and you talked to some people,
you find the good places,
but I have to tell you,
as far as scenery goes,
it's,
um,
it doesn't even look real.
And um,
the other day we took a boat out to the island of Capri
and uh,
I dunno,
they pulled the boat over,
they let us swim in the Mediterranean.
Obviously something I'm terrified to do cause I'm afraid of sharks.
But I finally believed them that there was no sharks.
I had my swimming goggles every five seconds I would look underneath to see if
there was a shark.
There is,
if I,
if I saw one,
I could somehow out swim it.
I just,
that's the part of,
of swimming in a sea or an ocean that I cannot handle.
It's my head above the water not seeing what the fuck is at me.
You know,
I reserve the right to at least see the shark coming at me so I can just scream,
you know,
underwater fuck.
You know,
maybe give it a little bit of a fucking,
you know,
a little fist bump,
something to it's fucking knows whatever the hell you supposed to do.
Maybe feed it one arm is they come over the top and smash it with another.
I always felt like that's the move.
Like if an attack dog is coming at you,
you just,
your feed the whatever arm you don't jerk off with and write with,
you feed them that arm,
just shove it right back into its fucking molders.
And then you come over the top,
you slammed down on its neck as you fucking lift up its head and you snap it's
fucking neck.
You know,
it's just an idea.
People,
I don't pretend to understand things.
So speaking of a physical harm,
the lovely Nia,
um,
last night she,
uh,
she,
she like bent down to get something out of her bag and this is little fucking
ledge above it that you can stick like a couple of glasses and a bottle of
water.
And she was underneath it,
bent down,
came up full speed in the corner of it,
hit the fucking top of,
she hit the top of her head right on the corner of it,
like brutally hard.
And um,
I gotta tell you,
I feel bad that she's not part of this fucking
little story here.
See if I'll bring her in because I failed miserably as a human being.
Yeah.
Nia,
do you want to be in on this story of you hitting your head?
Okay.
I okay.
I'm setting it up now.
So anyways,
she fucking hits her head.
I like fucking Bam.
All right.
Sounded like somebody dropped a suitcase on the floor
and then I swear to God,
she hit her head.
She goes,
she grabbed her head and then I swear to God,
she just started crying
like a goddamn toddler.
And I have to be honest with you.
Okay.
I didn't know what the fuck to do.
I just got to the point near where you hit your head and you started crying like
a toddler.
That'd be like,
it's hard because that's what it reminded me of.
It's like when a little kid,
like if an adult hits there,
you know,
stubs,
their toe hits the for this God damn mother fucker.
Yeah.
And you blame your whole family live in Rome,
you know,
that's what you do.
You started crying.
I did.
It was really painful balling.
Yeah.
And I was honest,
Israel myself.
On a scale of one to five,
five being the best,
how would you know know?
How would you rate my reaction to Oh,
zero
weeks I went in and I get you some
tissues.
That's what bill did.
I didn't know what to do it for him.
Mad Boom.
I was shocked at first because it really did feel like someone had just come up
and just walk me on the Noggin.
So I was shots.
Then the pain started kicking in and it was really,
really like,
it was like that little,
it was,
it was that corner,
no ledge.
And it went right into my scalp and I didn't know if I was bleeding or what.
And I,
I think he had,
normally I'd be like,
like most people,
but it's just,
I don't know what happened,
just the flood gates open and it felt better to cry than to pretend like it was
just like,
aw,
like a nuisance.
Like it really,
really hurt.
So bill's like,
oh no,
are you okay?
So we're good.
So what else was I supposed to do?
So we're good so far with that.
Okay.
So I'm just sitting there crying and he goes,
oh,
and he runs into the bathroom.
He doesn't even get me a tissue like a proper clean.
He gets me Twitter,
Neymar.
Okay.
If there is a choice between tissue,
paper and toilet paper to comfort someone,
please find the Kleenex.
It's softer.
It's just,
you know,
it's just,
it's a little thing,
but it makes a big difference.
So then he starts wiping my away.
Okay.
Rubbing it on.
He's a white man.
My Shit.
You shape for my eye to the other I using my chin.
They were huge.
I never seen anybody cry.
Wasn't big tears,
tears.
It wasn't like,
oh baby,
you know,
it was,
he was just scraping my funny,
I gotta be honest with,
with this toilet paper going been tears.
I gotta be honest with you.
It was fucking,
it freaked me out.
And what's the worst oh moment of comfort and you've ever heard in your life,
Hey,
loss for what to do.
Cause it was like you stopped being like a woman and you became like this two
year old and it was just like,
boom.
You're just like,
damn,
I didn't know what to do.
We were at home and when it got you in Popsicle,
Oh and then you said,
do you want some water?
I'm like,
what the fuck?
Water had to
do with anything.
That's what my parents always did.
If you hurt yourself and you cry,
they went and they got your water right out of there and then you sat down and
your face was all dry.
Salting.
They said,
oh,
I come back on site again.
And so I spent most of my childhood outside this with parents.
Did all right guys,
site,
Hey,
your kids,
you driving me.
That's get outside and you just them outside.
That's what you wanted to do with me in that moment.
You wanted to send me away so you wouldn't have to deal with it anymore.
I just wanted you to stop fucking crying.
I don't mean that in a bad way,
but it's just like to see another adult.
Nick,
can you imagine if I,
if I ever hit my fucking head and started crying the way you did?
I mean,
what would you know what would be coming out of your mouth?
I don't know.
I'd be like,
Oh,
a baby and I hold it to my chest or whatever and I'd rub your back.
You're full of shit.
If I fucking hit my head and started crying like a little girl
wasn't really that like,
it was like a little,
uh,
it was,
we went to style it.
I have,
I'm fucking spammer here.
He's stammering jackets.
You for 12 years.
I've never seen you.
I've seen you like you see me cry before.
A couple times in the kitchen you fucking cut yourself with a knife and even
then you didn't cry as much.
That was like,
you know,
you had a balloon in the thing,
went off your wrist and float it up in the air.
There was just no comfort in your,
it was a,
yeah,
I haven't read.
I will admit.
Um,
not only did I drop the ball in that moment,
it's been 24 hours and I still don't have a better approach.
It was so fucking bizarre.
Don't ever do that again.
Yeah.
All right.
The thing is the really sort of horrible thing about it,
the biggest injustice of it all,
the fact that you weren't able to come from me is that I was trying to plug in
your fucking computer.
Isn't that amazing?
I knew somehow it would come back to me and it'd be my fault that your dumb ass
ducked underneath the legend then lifted your head up.
Ric flair wouldn't have done it.
That hard to sell a fucking,
I didn't realize it was there.
I was plugging in your computer and you,
you'll be on Udacity to be the worst comforting person in that moment.
Ever scratching my face.
Would that when one ply toilet paper while say big tears,
big team,
what's his like what does that even mean?
So it was me.
I would feel the little league again.
No bad,
no bad.
A big tears but tears.
So when
big tears over and over again,
what did that mean?
You were just commenting on it.
I,
I didn't,
I didn't know what to do.
I mean you won't crying at a fucking level like I made.
I've been at funerals and seeing people cry to what the fuck you were doing.
I didn't know what to do.
Okay.
I'm sorry you caught me off guard.
Well tell me,
what am I supposed to say?
Just give me a fucking supposed to like,
you know,
take me into your arms and like hold me and like rub my back or something.
That sounds like a commercial for one of those love songs,
like time life presents.
It doesn't seem like a real thing that people do to what [inaudible] telling
you.
That's what I would like.
You asked me,
so I'm telling you what I would like.
I'd like your sunglasses to not be so big about that.
I'm showing Jackie O on this trip,
Jackie o g shit
as my part of the podcast and I'm going back outside.
Oh,
can we talk about the lady at the airport?
But Lady,
the fucking lady at the Union meeting for the lady pilots,
The New York Times article article about the lady pilots.
Ladies need,
we had zero fights.
10 days high.
Five high five high five right?
Zero fucking fights.
We had one moment.
Yeah,
we're down at the fucking pool.
Okay.
Obviously one of us wants to be there.
One of us doesn't take a guess.
Who doesn't want to be in the blazing fucking son?
Me.
So I'm down there and everybody is all can fucking concerned.
All these beautiful olive skin people running around trying to find enough
umbrella to cover my body.
That's white light.
The Mozzarella,
right,
like the,
that like the Mozzarella,
um,
like the Buddha but sweaty like the [inaudible].
So she hands me this abridged version of the New York Times.
And I read this thing and it's about,
um,
pilots.
So I was like,
I got to see the,
see what's going on here.
This is interesting to me.
And it was about how all the,
there's very few female pilots and not only the very few of them when they get
pregnant,
there is just this completely archaic system involved to try and help them,
you know,
during that time when they have an a kid and part of it had to do with,
using that breast pump so that,
you know,
if they want to breastfeed their kid naturally,
which is totally the way to go,
I would think,
you know,
the way God made you,
um,
I don't know if they didn't have the time or whatever.
So I'm reading this fucking article.
So in protests,
wait a
second.
So this is really quickly.
So the thing is,
yeah,
you breastfeed a kid,
some people breastfeed for,
you know,
ridiculous amount of time.
But gender is how old the kid gets.
Yeah.
Cause at some point it's like four and all this other crazy that's all people
made about.
But the typical thing from what I understand is that you breastfeed them on the
breath,
so about six months and then six months you ween them off the breast and you
give them the bottle,
but you still want to give them breastmilk.
Right?
So you got to use that breast pump,
the apparatus to get the milk out.
Cause if you don't your breast becoming gorge,
it's really painful,
you know,
leaking all over the place,
et cetera.
So the idea is that,
you know,
these female pilots have had children,
they're going back to work,
but they still want to give their kids breast milk,
but they need time,
approximately 20 minutes to pump.
Right.
And so what they're fighting for is the time and the resources and
the time off and all of that.
Or is it time off or just a way so that they can,
I'm not exactly sure.
Right.
What I'm,
we were both in the Sunbury and this article.
So yeah.
So that's the whole point.
Of course the upper management is not listening because they're also in the
meantime from what I've read on websites are beginning to cut corners in the
airline safety and having these weird fucking flight plans to try to get the
planes.
They're quicker to,
uh,
maybe have a few more flights or whatever,
save a little bit of fuel.
And the pilots are starting to be like,
you know,
one guy in particular and you know,
you're fucking with your career,
wrote a letter saying that they were doing that.
And of course the cooperation gave their basic fucking response.
So anyways,
not only are they not listening to the ladies,
they're not even listening to,
according to some pilots,
you know,
the basic safety rules of the FAA.
Right.
So anyway,
so this woman has a problem and she wants to protest,
you know,
their treatment of female pilots,
particularly pregnant female pilots,
nursing,
nursing.
So they're in a fucking meeting and some conference room and the woman takes her
breast out.
It hooks up the pump to it and starts pumping breast milk out of her fucking
breasts in front of everybody there and they say that the guys shifted
uncomfortably and stared at the floor and the way they presented it was like
there was something wrong with that behavior by the guys.
I mean that's fucking insane.
She just took a body part out.
You're not supposed,
it wasn't our elbow.
It was a breast and she starts pumping milk out of it
does.
She really did.
I can't remember that part.
Like she just,
I thought she just took it out and load was like,
this is what a breast pump looked like,
bellows and that sort of thing.
But she actually hooked it up.
I don't remember.
That's it.
They've got to remember.
See,
I thought,
I thought she just took it out and was just like,
this is what you do when you,
you pump breast milk people.
Yeah.
I didn't think that she,
she took it out.
I,
that's me.
Yeah.
I don't think that she actually took it out and bid the physical pumping.
All right.
Well she didn't take it out then.
I don't have a problem.
I think she just demonstrating,
but it's,
but it's still made people uncomfortable because they were like,
what are you doing right now?
And she,
her whole thing was like,
yeah,
this is what I gotta do to feed my kid.
Why don't you allow me the time and the resources to do it?
No,
but that's why I gotta be honest with you,
aside from being sexist,
that's why corporate doesn't want to hire women
is because that they don't want to deal with that
this,
yeah,
no,
they definitely,
they definitely don't want to do it.
Yeah.
They underpay.
The men forget about,
they don't want to fucking pay women and they certainly don't have to pay for
time off.
And also a lot times they're trying to get these peak the guys to fly faster,
taking unsafe fucking roots and whatnot and like,
oh,
okay.
I thought she took a titty out.
Okay.
She didn't take it.
I don't think she took her city,
took the breast pump out.
Oh,
I was sitting there going like,
I know,
I know that we're cave man.
And I'm like,
how the fuck?
It's like,
I really don't think so.
Like that.
That would be kidding.
What would they go?
Oh,
allude in a something.
Act like if you took your balls out through your zipper or you shook your
ticket,
somebody or you even move somebody.
I mate you.
Unless you're in the sales,
unless you're in sales and you're bringing it in such a ridiculous,
this amount of money,
like you're not only you done,
you're blackballed.
And that interest industry.
Well that was what the fight was about because I was looking over at you and I
was going to be like,
she took a fucking,
and you immediately rolled your eyes like,
Oh God,
here he goes again.
He's going to go off on some fucking rent,
trash and women.
And you rolled your eyes.
And in that moment I was just like,
I'm sorry.
Are we on the fucking Amalfi coast?
And you're rolling your eyes at me and I,
you know,
granted,
I ain't going,
I had a couple of fucking Johnny Walker said me.
Okay.
And I fucking stormed off.
And what did I do?
Where did I go near to the gym?
That's right.
Where have I gone to every fucking day to the gym.
I go to the gym every day unless you're giving me shit about it.
Um,
giving you shit about it.
You can take a day off because bill,
you know,
you have a tendency to overdo things and then you're like,
ha ha ha my hamstrings.
So it's like go,
go,
go.
And I'm just like,
you're allowed to have a day off from working out.
You just watched.
You really want to get a special coming up and you can't be a fat fuck despite
what all these fucking actresses say out there,
that that's only a female thing.
It may act like guys could just show up as a bloated booze headed.
Fuck,
you can't,
oh,
you can do it.
It certainly does not help your fucking career.
And I hate actress is trying to act like the fucking heart.
Throbs aren't these chiseled guys was square jaws,
full heads of hair and fucking abs.
They all are people magazine's 50,
famous,
50 beautiful fucking people every goddamn year.
It's never stayed there.
We still want a couple of fatties to act like they're actually down to earth.
But at the end of the fucking,
even then they make them wear like a Santa Claus suit.
Right.
And everybody else is absolutely fucking now they're not putting Jonah Hill on
that list or something like this.
Yeah,
no,
this is this thing.
And whatever they say,
they say a guy is,
is,
is a fat fuck.
They call it.
He's an every man.
He's relatable.
That's what they're saying.
You're a dumb fat fuck who married above.
He plays the dad.
Normally the every man that shabby,
every man plays like a dad on a sitcom.
Yup.
Don In his,
uh,
in his friend and his chubby friend.
Dom is fucking hell.
So they have that fucking guy.
So,
I dunno what,
so you guys can sit there and be like,
oh,
there's an an easy guy to manipulate.
All right.
I then they have the woman they give,
they give the guy something to fucking jerk off to.
I'm pretty big man.
Do you think I jerk off to sitcoms?
I'm just saying they give him a fucking hardy from day one.
That's what they did.
This is what it is.
I wrote [inaudible]
no,
I always thought it was adorable though.
Even though he's a little chubby.
Tom Bosley,
who's that?
He played from happy days with,
no,
I know,
again,
I always thought Kevin and James kind of adorable on king of kings queens.
Especially that episode where Kerry,
his wife is trying to learn how to code.
He's on the stripper pole.
She's trying to learn how to dance,
you know,
cause she,
wants to beat sexy and do something cool and he ends up teaching her how to pole
dance and he's great at it.
Yeah.
Oh my heart with that episode.
That's what he had to do.
Yeah.
Basically give an Olympic level performance.
No.
The fact that he was just agile,
it's got that Jack Black thing where they're like a heavy guy but they fucking
can outrun anybody and they can do like handstands and shit.
Yeah,
they just like a sandwich.
I like that.
Yeah.
I think that's cool because it's like you don't have to be,
you don't have to look like Zac Efron to be like a physical person.
I know,
but at the end of the fucking day,
like there's a pressure on everybody in Hollywood to be in shape.
And I remember that when I watched one of those meet the parents and there's
that swimming pool scene and and remote Ben Stiller throws the,
goes up to spike the ball and he hits the deniros daughter.
I remember looking at go like Ben Stiller.
Head abs.
Yeah.
Comedians never had abs.
Yeah,
he got more in shape.
The more movies the movies he did.
That's,
yeah,
you got it.
Cause what?
Ha No,
cause what happens is,
is the tree they pick away at you.
They trash out.
You're fucking look,
I told you that.
How critics work is you could have the most perfect show ever and then they'll
just stay.
Just pick it.
How you look.
When,
did you ever do a shirtless scene in a movie?
Yeah.
You would?
What if it was like tomorrow?
When do you like panic or would you just go with it?
No,
I do.
Yeah,
But what you gotta do is stare into it.
Like will Ferrell.
Yeah,
you can't go into that.
If you had a belly you can't do,
you can't stand this sucking and then it would actually push it out and then you
just,
then it,
it's everything in life is,
if you try,
anytime you start covering up,
people just sense it.
It's like a comic on stage.
The second you go on your heels,
the crowd without even talking to one another senses that they were in control
and then the heckles come,
well what are your,
so you're working out like crazy because you're trying to prepare for your
special,
but like what are your goals?
Like,
what's your,
what do you,
one of my goals?
Like are you trying to no,
I
one 72 is the way I have to be with,
with fucking HD TV.
Oh,
that's how you feel comfortable on camera.
That's your camera on camera.
Wait.
Okay.
Yeah.
There's one 71 72 that's basically it isn't,
everybody in Hollywood knows what fucking wait this supposed to anybody.
People will make youtube videos.
You make enough of them,
you know there's a tipping point,
right?
Yeah.
You can get away with it where all of a sudden,
yeah,
you start looking like you're walking into you getting carried and it's not that
much like one 72 was actually underweight for me,
but on camera it looks good.
So you have to do that.
So let's,
I'm saying like I,
I have empathy for,
you know,
people talking about,
the pressures of it,
but,
but my,
it kind of goes out the window where it was like,
well everybody in that business is on a treadmill eating a fucking apple.
Everybody fucking works out.
Everybody does.
You have to,
you have because you do look bigger on cameras and you're also in,
this is the thing,
the thing that I find fucking hilarious about social media is like just every
day I get trashed every fucking day by somebody on Twitter or Facebook.
I mean I've been able to find the humor in it and all you got to get outside of
it and be like,
all right.
I mean I just got an eight good ones.
One bad ones,
I'll take that 80% 80 90% good.
I'll take that.
But like especially everyone,
so if somebody gets moved to a really good one,
well you always,
you hear me laugh,
I read it to you like it's a really fucking good one.
I I got to give it up,
but just
I did.
I tell you that I'm very concerned about like that share that I did that's
coming out next year.
What's it called?
I'm concerned about things.
No,
I did an episode.
I did two episodes of a TV show,
a guest starring role on a Netflix show that's coming out next year.
I don't know when it's coming on next year,
what node is called.
It's on Netflix.
Oh.
And it's got,
it's called Santa Clarita Diet.
And I have a small part,
but I'm in two episodes and I'm very concerned about how I'm going to look
weight wise.
Well,
cause it just kind of happened.
It was
put it out there.
You just put it out there.
There's people who hate their lives and are licking their chops to fucking
trash.
So now they're going to watch it and be like,
you remember when you said back in August?
They won't say that.
Yeah,
because then you'll understand like they want it.
They want to be mean.
They just want to be like,
what the fuck,
blah,
blah is yes,
it's what they do.
I look,
yeah.
You know it's funny,
I don't get at it because
I used to do that and if I was just doing what I fucking trashed everything I
still do.
But like when I was,
when I was younger,
there was no internet.
But believe me,
if there was an internet,
I would have trashed fucking,
you know,
Jesus Christ.
Half of those new wave bands because I thought I was listening to the real shit
and you know,
have people,
I was listening to a bunch of guys were fucking lipstick.
I've got motley Crue was better than fucking boy George and they had the same
fucking waiver backstage writer with the lip gloss and makeup artist.
But these guys were singing about the devil and the other guy was thinking about
his failings.
Although what's his face one time?
Yeah.
Mommy crosser came around,
you know,
you know I'm a dreamer,
but my underwears pink.
That was such a Vince Neil,
right?
Yep.
Is that Tommy Lee on piano piano?
I thought he played,
he played the beginning part.
You played at the beginning part of that.
Vince Neil had to run away high so he didn't come home low.
Okay.
See his heart was like an open book for the whole world to read.
All right.
Spaces in that band is Nikki Sixx and this man.
Oh,
he's maximize.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Those guys are super duper famous,
super duper famous and they had their last show last year,
the same night.
I was always working in La and they will run around the corner at the staple
center and that was the final one ever.
If they signed a contract,
Mia.
So if they ever come back then they're going to have to sue themselves.
Do you understand that?
No,
I know.
I don't understand that either.
I don't know why they signed a contract.
I think it was because all those people like Cher and fucking uh,
Nipsey Russell.
I forget who else.
Somebody else will always say that this is,
this is the final tour.
The WHO,
the WHO said a bunch of final fucking tour.
All those farewell tour where,
well this is the last one.
Yeah.
It's a really cheesy way for some people to just get your ticket sales up.
Alright.
I gotta read this.
Thank you for being on the podcast.
Yeah.
Thank you for having me.
Hey Mia.
Hey,
great vacation,
honey.
If you ever hit your head again and start crying like a two year olds,
just give me Kleenex.
Okay.
That's all I ask.
They'll give me toilet paper
deal.
I don't have to say anything.
What do you mean?
You don't have to say anything.
You have to come from me.
Jerk.
Give me three things to say.
Are you okay?
Come here.
It's going to be all right.
You cried way longer than that.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and you just have to like,
come here,
come here.
It's going to be all right.
Disconnected.
Are you from human emotion that I have to teach you how to comfort somebody?
Crying was a sign of weakness where I came from.
Okay,
well fuck was a long time man.
The fuck up.
Well man or a woman you did.
You know?
I don't know
what happened to my I fry.
All right.
You know what happened?
No,
I'm just really tired of hearing about your slapped in the face of and a bud
light
Rockwellian childhood or whatever it is that you're always describing.
They stuck your head under the water of an above ground.
I totally stopped seeing bubbles call you back up again.
Like you really like paint a picture like you grew up in like this hard scrabble
kind of fucking environment.
It didn't,
you don't think so?
You fell out of a tree and your parents are like,
shake it off.
Okay.
That is what happened though,
right?
What was it you that fell out of history?
No,
I got hit by a car.
Oh,
you poor baby.
And my parents set away the ambulance cause they didn't like the hospital they
will taking us to,
and I got in a cab and they took,
took us to the hospital.
They want it to remember my mother kept telling me,
don't go to sleep,
don't go to sleep.
Oh no wonder.
Okay.
All right.
Well I get it now.
No.
Yeah.
I'm not saying I fucking grew up in a,
in a,
in a slump.
I'm just saying that it was,
it was different back then.
It was,
yeah,
it was different.
All right.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's all I'm saying.
I'm not saying I'm a fucking bad ass,
but like I,
I'm not gonna lie.
Apologize for having a fucked up world view.
Okay.
Adults taught me this shit,
so,
all right.
Yeah,
go talk to them.
Talk to your parents about,
Hey Chris.
I know just anybody in roughly there in big with the Mr. Yeah,
but you know something yet there wasn't overcorrection
meaning one dead.
There's a reason why it went from fucking walled up.
Douche is like me who only know how to go.
Oh,
big tears.
Big Tears.
I grab toilet paper and make a u shape fucking sign around your face that we
went from that to those fucking hipster.
Who Do you wearing beard?
Fuck bearded.
Fucking pussies.
Who Act like they're 40 10 years old and awkward non their first fucking day
generation thing that they're tougher than the like the next generation.
Is that just what happens?
I don't think I'm tough
than anybody.
Pretty much to me and I don't feel like I'm tougher than anybody like anybody
now that there's so many fucking places in just the United States,
a law where kids grow up way tougher than I did,
but what I'm doing is I'm defending the fact that I don't know what to do.
One or the adults.
All right,
so fucking head in prize like a two year old.
I'm not trying to have something like a Olympic backstory here before you watch
me.
Yeah.
We play ping pong or some other stupid fucking sport that nobody cares about.
I got to tell you,
the pink pong is pretty cool.
And I did watch the,
uh,
I think,
watch a little bit of the,
uh,
the,
the volleyball.
I have watched the United States unfortunately lost to Italy.
I did watch that.
You fucking slippers that loud.
Um,
you guys know what I'm saying?
What the Fuck God damn adults starts crying like a two year old.
What are you supposed to do with Jesus Christ other than beat?
Like for the love of God,
can you get your shit together?
I felt like being like Barnes and not to just grabbing dia,
it'd be like,
all right,
dollar shave club.
Okay.
A dollar shave club wants to thank everybody for subscribing and they also want
to try to get new people to subscribe.
So right now they're going to give new members a month of the executive razor
for fucking fleet it just for buying it too.
But Dr cabbies,
easy shave butter.
Uh,
we're super excited.
Evidently,
uh,
they're doing it for you.
Now,
let me remind you why millions of others have joined as proud members of the
club.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing razors right to your door for a third of
the price of what the greedy razor corporations charge.
That means when you joined dollar Shave Club,
you can afford to shave with a fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic.
I get a first class shave when I use the exam.
I don't cause I don't fucking use the thing cause they already had a fucking
razor and I got enough fucking bullshit in my life.
Okay?
It doesn't mean it doesn't work.
I hate out this fucking,
this ad shit.
They always have to act like you're using it and not using it.
All right.
I think it's a great fucking idea and I think it's useful for my listeners for
fuck sakes.
All right.
When you guys use the executive with Dr Carver's shave butter,
the blade just gently glides for the smoothest shave ever.
Shave butter isn't your average shave cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula with high quality natural ingredients,
leaving your skin unbelievably soft and smooth.
Now's a great time to join dollar shave club.
New members.
Get a who buy a tape,
a tube of shave butter.
Get a month of the executive razor for free.
Take advantage of this special offer today.
It's available by going to dollar shave club.com/bar that's dollar shave
club.com/bar all legal zoom,
everybody.
Holy Shit.
It's national maker well month,
so it's time to check an important item off your to do list@legalzoom.com
spending a few minutes right now on your will or trust means you can enjoy a
worry free summer.
Eh,
it doesn't matter if I die,
I go in my affairs in order.
Shotgun of fucking 12 pack.
Jump on a motorcycle with no helmet.
I'm worried.
Free summer filled with family vacations and barbecues.
Legal Zoom makes it easy.
They're not a law firms,
so you don't have to pay to have to take time out of your day for office visits
or pay expensive hourly rates.
Yeah.
But why the fuck would I do?
What would you make a will out without a lawyer?
Okay,
that's a that,
that's a good talking point.
Instead,
you get flat rate pricing.
You can save $100 with legal zooms,
will or trust the state plant bundles.
If you don't know whether a will or trust is right for you,
don't worry,
you'll work with an independent attorney.
Oh,
there it is.
There it is.
An independent attorney.
See,
this is how they keep the costs down,
the outsource their attorneys available.
Independent attorneys available in 48 states who could answer questions and
recommend an estate plan that fits your needs.
Uh,
saved money today by doing the right thing during national.
Make a will month@legalzoom.com and don't forget to enter burn in the referral
box at checkout to save even more.
Spend your time with your family this summer.
Let legal zoom take care of the legal stuff.
Legal zoom.com hey,
that's legalzoom.com.
Lastly,
but certainly not leastly,
stamps.com everyone mailing and shipping are a routine part of your running your
business important.
Keeps your operation go.
Why does he,
that should be important with a colon mailing and shipping are a routine part of
running your business.
Dot,
dot,
dot.
Important Comma keeps your operation going.
Dot Dot,
dot.
Do Your fucking kid write that.
But if you're making constant trips to the post office dash,
that's a routine you need to change.
There's much more,
a much more convenient way.
Dash stamps.com stamps.com makes all of the surfaces of the post office right to
your desk or it brings them right to your desk.
Buy and print official US postage using your own computer and printer.
Print postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of male than just hand your mail over to the mail carrier,
be it male,
female,
or transgendered.
You'll never waste valuable time going to the post office again so you can focus
on what really matters growing your business.
All right,
I use stamps.com whenever I,
you know,
make a poster and I want to whore myself out afterwards and meet people with
sweaty fucking hands.
Um,
do you know somebody recently came to his show and said,
Bill,
I know you don't like sweaty hands.
And they gave me the fist one.
Oh.
I was like,
thank God.
And then we went to take the picture and they put their arm,
they put their hand on my back and I felt their hand drying into my shirt.
Is it stuck to my back?
Sweating,
lost disgusting things that has ever happened to me right now.
Sign up for stamps.com and use my last name,
birth for this special offer.
Four week trial plus a $110 bonus offer that includes posting and a digital
scale.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinthatstamps.com enter
[inaudible].
Alright.
Okay,
here we go.
Here we go.
Going to do the reeds here for this week.
All right.
East Coast road trip.
A Billy the red kid.
I'm from Chile.
Yup.
It's a country.
I know.
It's in South America.
It's on the fucking west coast.
You can't.
Um,
he says,
I'm not going to tell you to come and do your show here because nobody knows you
in this inside of this world.
All right.
I have a four year old son and a lovely,
lovely lady and we're hoping to go to you go on vacation to the USA next year.
So it would be great if you could tell me what city,
uh,
we have to see.
And he says,
thanks.
I'm going to try to say,
uh,
I'm trying to translate.
I can't translate this.
It's thanks Ian.
Abrazo Dossetti el Otro Lado del Mundo.
The fuck does that mean if he insulted me?
I want to know what he said.
Hang on a second.
I got to write this up.
All right.
Let me hit pause.
Hang on.
Ah,
Jesus.
It means thanks.
A hug from the other side of the world,
right?
Yeah.
The other side of the world.
I wasn't that Nice.
Um,
well,
I know what to suggest for adults,
but you have a four year old son,
so I got to take that into account.
Um,
I would suggest possibly Florida and doing Disney world,
but uh,
you know,
they got the fucking,
those mosquitoes down there that,
but they're also in Brazil.
So I don't know if they'd come in your way.
I have no fucking idea.
What I would do is if you want to do,
don't do Disney world,
I would do Disneyland.
Yeah.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
What the hell does a four year olds want to do?
All right,
I'm just going to tell,
I can only speak for someone who doesn't have kids.
I loved San Francisco,
Seattle,
uh,
Boston,
New York.
Okay.
I mean,
if you're going to start,
I would go with one of those.
Chicago,
Chicago is such a great,
if you want to get a vibe of the United States,
you know,
get a big city vibe with people who were also kind of fucking,
a little bit of that kind of rubes in Chicago.
You know,
it's sort of a weird thing.
It's like it's a city,
but it's still country.
It's still farmland around it.
You know what I mean?
You see people who were in shape,
you've seen people who are going to have a heart attack in about three steps.
They got great fucking food.
Uh,
there's sports crazy.
They're great people.
They're overtly fucking racist.
It's beautiful summers.
It's ungodly cold and he get the whole fucking,
they get the whole thing,
the whole thing.
You'll find Trump supporters and Hillary supporters and all of that fucking
shit.
Um,
it's right in the of the country.
I Dunno,
you guys live,
you live near the water in Chile.
Christ the fucking is only like what,
30 miles wide.
If you've had enough of that,
I go to Chicago,
I guess.
Depends on what you guys do.
If you like to eat here in the barbecue,
I'd go down south,
don't sleep on the south.
There's a bunch of great places to go to.
Maybe you can build it around a sporting event,
you know,
some auto racing or baseball.
Maybe the football that's coming up is a bunch of things that you could do.
Um,
but if you just want to go to like just a really cool city with great places to
eat and stuff to see,
uh,
San Francisco,
Seattle,
Boston.
Yeah,
New York are amazing.
Um,
I dunno if those would be mine that I would pick.
All right.
But no matter what,
you're going to have a good time.
Alright.
Mussolini.
Hey Bill.
While in Italy,
did you happen to notice any Mussolini souvenirs for sale?
I was in Rome a few years ago and they seem to be in most do stands bunch of
fastest fascist.
Sorry.
Um,
no,
actually I didn't,
but you know,
I dunno.
I think it's funny that like Americans like to do that fascist shit.
I liked the,
you know,
say that shit too.
But who's kidding,
who,
we don't exactly have the greatest track record with our foreign policy,
certainly over the last 16 fucking years,
wouldn't you say?
You know what I mean?
And if you're really going to get a tentacle over,
since we won World War II,
you know,
and certainly since Russia fell and there was no one really to keep us in check,
we've kind of been,
you know,
the way corporations sort of dictate a foreign policy.
We've been quite the clients for the last at least fucking 30 years,
2026 sites sick.
Um,
so yeah,
I wouldn't judge anybody.
Mousseline he is a part of their fucking history.
If I saw Muesli a souvenir,
I buy one.
If they had a Hitler badge,
I'd fuck it by that.
Just,
I mean,
I'm fascinated with World War II.
What data stolen one.
I'd get that if they had an ice and higher one or a fucking,
uh,
William h Macy,
who's the fucking guy from Winston Churchill?
Yeah,
I buy all of those.
That's the Mount Rushmore or World War Two.
And then you got to have a,
what's his face there?
A Arnold from happy days.
What's the fucking guy from Japan?
He never,
he doesn't get enough love that guy.
You know,
he did just as much horrific shit.
What the fuck was his name?
Leader in Japan.
Was He an emperor?
I mean right there,
dude.
That's like some crazy,
I'm sorry.
Right?
That's a great Breslin character right there.
All right.
World War Two
emperor
tiger star.
No.
What the fuck?
That's not it.
Hang on a second.
Here we go.
Here.
We hope though.
He re Hodo.
Yeah,
by any of that shit.
Nia.
Either close the fucking curtain or leave it open.
You're killing me with my eyes over here.
Alright.
Bogus chocolate.
What do you think about this Nia?
Hey there Billy.
Sweet nuts.
Did you hear about this brother in New York who started a chocolate company
selling chocolate bars for $10 under the false pretenses that it was premium
chocolate.
It turns out it was shitting chocolate and they were using the cheapest of
ingredients while simultaneously trashing all over all other chocolate
companies.
Here's the link to the article.
What's your policy and buying niche products that are full of hype.
I actually did her about that and I think it's fucking hilarious.
You know,
I don't like,
you know,
Exxon Mobil finding out about global warming 30 years ago,
allegedly,
and then completely blowing it off.
But you know,
if somebody does the emperor's new clothes and like Brooklyn with some fucking
chocolate and sells it to a bunch of dopes,
I think it's funny.
They should definitely be panelized.
It's like when those,
they used to catch those people,
right?
Where was he selling it?
Like on the street?
On the subway,
on the,
like how they go about solving it.
MMM.
Comes up to you on the street and it's like trying to sell you a Rolex,
like,
you know,
pretty much any kind of street smarts that the shifts either fake or it's hot.
Right?
So if someone comes up to you and says this premium chocolate,
no,
no.
They went all out.
They had a whole book like this.
How the mass,
yeah,
I read about that.
They had all the packages
and I think it's fucking hilarious.
I thought they were talking about someone just sell it.
You know what that reminds me of?
It's like when they would,
they'll bust somebody like,
uh,
you know,
they'll have this premium tap water,
not tap water,
I'm sorry,
bottled water,
and then make the name.
Like in one month they have a $50,000 water bill because they're just taking it
out of their tap.
That shit is always been hilarious to me.
It's like the guy who figured out how to,
how to pick the lock or the parking meters was allegedly impossible to do when
some guys figured out how to do it,
but of course he got greedy and then ended up getting caught.
Just people who do shit like that.
It's just funny to me.
You know what I mean?
I know you rob a bank,
you don't use a gun.
It's funny to me.
All right.
You don't hurt anybody.
You just scare people.
You put,
you just hand them a note.
Yeah.
He had him a note with the money in a bag and you got whipped cream on your
face.
You didn't really plan it out.
It was an impulsive thing.
You know,
you decided you wanted a little better lunch.
If you don't stop opening and closing that motherfucker,
fuck her up of God damn going.
Yeah.
When are you going to close it and you can't close the,
the,
the curtain.
Yeah.
You can't close the curtain and close the door.
Please don't make me watch you do this.
Oh Gosh.
By Mia.
Why?
Alright.
Seeing x advice.
Hey Bill for Bill Flynn.
I'm a 20 year old guy and my girlfriend have a year broke up with me a couple of
months ago.
I'm starting to get over her and we go to different colleges.
So I think it will be easier to move on.
But we have the same friends and I know we will go to the same hangouts.
For example,
my buddy's birthday is in two weeks and she's going,
should I go up to her first and talk to her?
Like she didn't kick my heart in the ass or should I just say hi and sort of
ignore her for the rest of the party.
Thanks.
And have a nice day now.
Um,
this is what she gotta do.
Okay.
All right.
She dumped you so you didn't want it to end.
She did.
So you're hurting more than her is how I would probably guess how this is going
down.
So
mmm.
I would just,
first thing I would do is,
and my friends,
enough with this person who's having the birthday than I did,
it's worth putting myself into the position.
Okay.
If it isn't,
then just don't go to the party.
If it is,
if the person is important enough,
then when you go there,
I would absolutely say hello to her first.
You know,
just say good to see you.
Hope you're doing all right,
blah,
blah.
Um,
no need to be weird around me,
whatever.
All right.
And then I would just go about and have a great fucking time.
I would limit my drinking that night.
Cause you don't want to make a dumb decision because if you go there and you say
hello to her first and you're totally fucking cool.
Um,
for whatever fucking reason how people work when they break up with people,
they,
if the person is,
if they're that set thing,
if,
if the person's clinging,
the other person is is goes,
oh my God,
thank God I'm out of it.
But if they look like that getting on with their life,
even if the person just got done dumping them for some reason,
they'll try and hook up with them.
You don't want to hook up with this person again.
All right.
She made the decision and just,
I don't,
I don't get how that works,
but men and women both do that shit.
So I would just be totally cool.
Go to the birthday party.
I would not drink at this thing.
That would be a great move.
You stay sober.
This is what you want to be.
You don't want to be fast.
Eddie.
All right from the hustler.
Remember that when he gets all shit faced and Jackie Gleason stays fucking
sober,
Minnesota fats and he goes,
all right,
let's shoot some pool after fucking fast eddy down the whole bottle of fucking
bourbon that he kicks his ass and gives all the money back plus another fucking
10 grand.
I would,
if you're going to go to one,
I wouldn't be totally nice to her.
Say hello,
be totally cool.
Walk the fuck away.
And then just drink club soda is the whole night.
And then,
uh,
when it feels like the time is right,
it's starting to get to that point where everybody's getting fucking wasted
leave and then that's it.
That's how I would play it.
MMM.
God Damn it.
I wish somebody gave me that advice a long fucking time ago.
All right.
Let me pat myself on my back from my own fucking advice and seen it sounded good
to me.
Anyways,
here we go.
All right,
Bill,
my girlfriend is addicted to sex.
All right.
Collectively,
every guy listening to this.
Awe.
Um,
hey bill,
just wanted to let you know if you had an,
uh,
just want to know if he had any advice related to my relationship with my
girlfriend.
Uh,
as you probably read in the subject of this,
on this message,
there doesn't seem to be a downsize to the situation,
but there is,
since she can't control herself.
Recently my girlfriend visited me from California for a month and every day we
banged on the kitchen floor,
shower,
bedroom,
backyard.
It's set from up until the last day.
It was great until we got into an argument.
She kept trying to walk away and break up with me without a real reason until
she told me why.
Apparently,
uh,
apparently my girlfriend can't wait more than eight months without sex and after
eight months she doesn't care who she gets it from,
this word me and Piss me off at the same time we ended up staying together,
but I won't see her for a good while.
No idea.
When.
Now my worry is that she will cheat on me with other people during the time we
are apart.
Uh Oh.
And by the way,
I live in Texas.
Uh,
I would love some advice from my favorite comedian.
Um,
I would trust your instincts here.
Yeah.
Listen,
you can't get mad at her for the fact she told you what her deal is.
Okay.
She needs it.
She needs it all the fucking time.
She lives in California.
You live in Texas.
She actually was doing you a fucking favor by trying to break up with Dick cause
she doesn't want to cheat on you.
And um,
I dunno if this is just naturally how she's wired.
If,
I don't know if it's as an issue,
I don't know what the fucking deal is,
but all I know is the way she is.
Okay.
And she lives in California and you live in Texas and you don't know when she,
you're going to see her again.
Yeah.
You got to let this one go.
All right.
You don't need that anytime.
Okay.
You know,
you're with somebody,
you're trying to have a series fucking relationship and uh,
you know,
you can't be away from him for a certain amount of time or they're going to fuck
somebody else.
I mean,
I don't think man or woman a fantasizes is that for a,
any sort of significant serious or lifetime partners.
So I would,
um,
hey,
you know what,
you had a good time with her
and uh,
I let her go.
She's out in California.
Let her,
let her go do whatever the fuck she's going to do when,
uh,
I would try to find someone that's a little more wired like yourself and see if
that works.
All right?
Okay.
That's the podcast.
Uh,
okay.
I'm going to enjoy my last day here.
Hey,
thank you to the beautiful country of Italy and everybody,
uh,
from here that treated me and my wife so wonderfully.
We'll definitely get to come back once again.
Thank you everybody who came out to,
uh,
to my tour,
um,
through Ireland,
England,
Scotland,
Amsterdam,
Belgium and Germany.
Um,
could not have had more fun on this trip.
I definitely ready to get home.
I have not seen my fucking dog Cleo Leo since July 29th.
Um,
yeah,
I have not been in the United States since July,
so I got to get back before they fucking just cancel my God damn visa or
whatever the fuck it is.
All right.
That's it.
If you guys enjoyed the podcast,
if you'd like to donate,
this is an easy way to do it.
Uh,
next time you're going to buy something on Amazon,
just go to [inaudible] dot com first click on the podcast page and you just hit
the Amazon link,
right?
It'll take you right to Amazon.
Uh,
it doesn't cost you any extra money,
but I get credit for driving traffic that way.
If you want to do it,
I get it.
If you don't,
no problem.
And also,
if you'd like to see me do my first fucking show since my European tour in the
United States,
I will be in Reno on August 27th,
which with the absolutely fucking hilarious Todd wrecks,
one of the funniest fucking people I've ever met in my life.
He's the guy.
What are you saying?
Hey handsome.
One of the,
he said that to a cop one time that pulled us over when the guy was walking up
to the current.
What was so funny was he was a young baby face look at comp and we pulled this
over.
We were underneath a bridge.
So it echoed and think it was me,
him and law head.
And uh,
I think I lost six months of my life trying not to laugh when the cop walked up
and he said that he's one of the funniest guys I know.
And he is not going to be easy to follow.
So if you come out to the show,
do not show up late because Todd is,
every bit is funny as I'll ever fucking be.
All right,
that's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you on Thursday.